the only thing I know about Peru has to
do with llamas in all packets but I
really hope you don't eat them because
they're so cute all of our knowledge of
Peruvian food is based off of the
Emperor's New Groove my dad went to Peru
once I love pieces of beef wages llama
this was the steak of Tripoli tasted
like I'd be ordering steak burritos
chicken burritos
I like the veggies Oh what bad news get
the veggies when I'll onions in the
fries how are you this all the time
breakfast lunch and dinner maybe not
that but I use a lot yeah like a llama
no beans you know maybe a llamas made
out of no it's not think I do know that
Alana's not made out of beef have you
ever eaten a llama no this looks like it
could have been from Emperor's New
Groove I'm gonna make a bet that we're
not gonna like this oh we could draw our
names in it I'm right I was immediately
gonna write key be right in cows eat the
sauce it lingers like I can't get it out
of my mouth it probably tastes like a
scalloped potato you know that's seen in
hook where they all the kids are playing
imaginary with in Bude you know this
looks like some stuff out of that you
always think that that food to be
delicious
yeah this it's like ice cream but this
is not ice cream I feel like a witch
made this I feel like someone was like
God the leg of a crab it the tentacle of
a squid yeah this is finally gonna make
that girl I like fall in love with me
the thing I like about you soup
actually it's not that bad no it's good
it but it's like everything from the
ocean is in yeah cause turtle it tastes
like the ocean mm-hmm but until this is
her
Mel's good looks good this looks like
something you should have it Halloween
it's lighter than Jam but it's thicker
than jello right like you're about to
say a rhyme but when it gets in my mouth
I say hello
kinda minds me of the thing you rub on
women's bellies when they're getting the
ultrasound like petroleum jelly yeah I
think kids would love this cuz like it's
purple
that's fine it's got fruit in it fruits
awesome and it's like sugary cinema it's
great start off really strong with beef
dish I love that remember the beef dish
family I miss it it was good it's like
some of it was really eclectic which was
interesting then some of it was really
simple overall Bru yeah you got food
people gonna eat and seafood is pretty
good the corn stuff is fun and the
potatoes were confusing but overall I
need it give you a solid keep it at
least a 45 okay
you see my wallet pants it's impossible
to see them sad to come up friend table
your party why not that's why they're
festive colors it's just so sad what's
happening over there oh yeah you don't
know the half of it